Chinese president XI jinping's on his
way to Russia for a two-day visit
Russian leader Vladimir Putin is
welcoming what he calls China's
constructive role in trying to end the
war in Ukraine she says the relationship
with Russia is an all-encompassing
partnership coutinhu reports from
Beijing
Chinese president his most recent trip
was in June 2019. during an economic
forum sea will travel there again in
what's expected to be a major show of
Chinese support from Moscow as it
continues its invasion of Ukraine
with China and Russia working together
the world will have the driving force
toward multipolarity and a greater
democracy in international relations and
a global strategic balance and its
stability will be better insured the
visit comes as China seeks to expand its
role as a global leader and mediator
earlier this month it brokered a deal to
end seven years of strained relations
between Saudi Arabia and Iran
thank you some analysts believe it can
do the same for Russia and Ukraine in
February Chinese officials released a
peace plan calling for a ceasefire and
dialogue between both sides the Chinese
understand you
after several months both parties are
exhausted and they want to have the
Forum to start peace talks China can
offer large
and no other country can do that but
others say Beijing is reluctant and
unable to play this role due to the
West's extensive backing of Kiev it is
great power geopolitics going on there
it's very difficult to to play a
mediating role in that context and uh
the stakes are very high
Russia and Ukraine do not want to
negotiate at the moment so there is very
little China can play with
Beijing relies on economic trade with
Europe and says it's impartial in the
war but its claims of neutrality have
been questioned last year C declared a
No Limits partnership with Moscow
expanding trade between the two
countries has become an economic
Lifeline for the sanction hit country
C and Putin are also good friends and
have met 40 times including on Putin's
birthday
the United States says China is
considering providing Military Support
to Russia which Beijing denies she is
reportedly planning to speak to Vladimir
zelenski following his Moscow visit it
would be shu's first conversation with
the Ukrainian president since
hostilities broke out Kiev says it's
cautiously receptive to beijing's
involvement but a withdrawal of Russian
forces from any occupied territory must
be included in any peace deal
Katrina you al-dazeera Beijing
well both presidents released news
articles in state media ahead of
Monday's visit she wrote in a Russian
newspaper that relations between the two
countries are based on non-alignment and
non-confrontation against third parties
he also stressed that China is pursuing
reconciliation and peace in Ukraine
meanwhile Putin's article in China's
people's daily accused the U.S of
following a strategy of double
deterrence of Russia and China Putin
said it's becoming more acute and
assertive while Katrina use joining us
now from Beijing so what is President XI
actually hoping to achieve with this
well according to the article he
published in Russian State media on
Monday president Xi Jinping says that
this is a mission of peace and
friendship he wants to expand moscow's
relationship with Beijing and according
to Beijing it's important for the
International Community that Russia and
China are close in order to provide some
stability in a multi-polar system and
balance what Beijing says is the
hegemonic bullying of the Us and other
Western powers of course a big part of
this trip also is expanding economic
ties trade between Russia and China has
now worth about 190 billion dollars in
that sword since Russia has invaded
Ukraine by about 30 percent and a lot of
that is cheap oil and gas that China
gets and that's very beneficial of
course for Beijing but also Xi Jinping
is going to Russia to shore up his
support from Vladimir Putin at a time
when Beijing is really facing increasing
tensions increasing rivalry with the
United States with the United States as
allies and even European partners and
Beijing wants to make sure that Russia
is always in its corner and of course
this is going to be a huge uh diplomatic
symbol as well to the world this is the
biggest show of support that Russia will
have received since the beginning of its
invasion of Ukraine it's a big uh symbol
of solidarity that Beijing is showing
with Russia and I think because Russia
is so important for China Xi Jinping is
doing what he can in this visit to
somehow legitimize uh Vladimir Putin and
his war effort in Ukraine and of course
he says he's also going to share his
ideas about how to end the crisis and
the war there although he has failed to
blame Russia or to condemn this invasion
of Kev we heard in your report just a
couple of moments ago Alexander
O'Connell from the University of New
South Wales saying that Russia and
Ukraine don't want to negotiate at the
moment do we have any indication from
this visit how this will influence the
attempts to mediate in the Ukraine war
interesting time and certainly it's
significant that China has just come off
the successful brokering of a peace deal
between Saudi Arabia and Iran who are
estranged for seven years and Xi Jinping
is definitely wanting to capitalize on
that success and put forward China as a
global leader and alternative to the
United States and yes even a mediator
and I've heard analysts speak on two two
points about whether it can successfully
mediate between Ukraine and Russia on
one side uh China is a partner unlike
the United States which is able to talk
to theoretically at least both Ukraine
and Russia and it says that it's an
impartial and neutral party but the way
that this is not different from the way
that this is not the same as the
situation in the Middle East with Saudi
Arabia and Iran is that we have very
strong extensive and clear military
backing of Ukraine by the United States
by several European countries and China
at the same time is trying to also
balance its own interests in its own
relationship with Europe it needs trade
with Europe to survive economically and
at the same time it doesn't want to poke
the Russian bear so to speak he doesn't
want to do anything to uh make this
relationship with Moscow vulnerable
because they want to make sure that
Vladimir Putin is very much in this on
the side of Beijing when Beijing needs
it to be when it comes to issues around
Taiwan to South China Sea for example so
it will be interesting to see how far Xi
Jinping goes when he uh when he visits
Russia when he talks to Vladimir Putin
but at least he can say well we tried to
mediate talks we try to push for
dialogue and push for peace and even if
Beijing is not fully successful at this
end it will say that it pushed its
effort and pushed its image as a
negotiator as a neutral party in this
conflict and as a global leader Katrina
you talking to us from Beijing Katrina
thank you very much indeed